As our learners work through assignments,
it can be helpful
to check on their progress
as well as see their code
in a working environment
in order to help them troubleshoot
any issues that they're having.
And we can do all of that from within
RStudio Cloud. For this walk through
I've added myself as a learner
to our data visualization workspace,
which we can confirm
by clicking on the members tab.
There are two ways to access learner work.
One is to click on an individual's name
from the members tab.
When we do this,
we're taken to our learner's projects.
In this case, our learner has only worked
on assignment one.
But we can click into their work
and see what they've created,
as well as run their code.
It's important to note that when we open
a learner's project in RStudio Cloud,
we are not creating a separate
copy of the work --
we're directly accessing their work.
Any changes we make here will be
incorporated into the learner's project.
One advantage of this
is that we can write comments or provide
sample code for our learners
in an asynchronous manner.
Another point worth mentioning is that if
we as educators, or really anyone
with the moderator or administrative role
within the workspace,
opens a learners work while
the learner is working on it,
the learner will be disconnected
from their project.
It may be helpful
to let learners know that this may happen,
especially if you and your learners
are working asynchronously.